camera Madson got to know Rob Kardashian
well Rob Dancing with the Stars and
Cameron is in New York City right now
and you actually talked about Rob with
his mom Kris Jenner right I asked her
about Rob's romance that keeps making
news and we also talked about the OJ
mini series what does she think they got
right and what she says they got wrong
understand he really had nothing to do
with that I know and next week's episode
they're teasing a fight between you and
Robert and you being angry that he's
defending OJ it did that really happen
yeah I mean there was definitely tension
there and you know there you know she
was one of my best friends and he was my
ex-husband and we were on different
sides nobody did
check that's what Chris told me about
the miniseries and she also has no
complaints Khloe Kourtney stop running
watching the episodes what in watching
is with some things that you think that
they just got wrong well in one of the
scenes actually they show my kids
sitting in front of a TV watching the
reading of what they thought was a
suicide letter from OJ Robert to whom it
may concern they were watching TV and
sort of heard their dad's name and so
they were chanting Kardashian we were
hanging out in my house and and that
didn't happen
another thing Kris says they got wrong
selma Blair's appearance I was pregnant
with Kendall when we were going through
the trial so there you go
you